he's waited for me
i've waited for him
well i don't think i understood it at
first and when my daughter was in
college
i understood that they actually taught
there's i think a book called
uh
something uh chainsaws and
that is a text
and that the term final girl i hadn't
heard
i hadn't heard it
until i was sent a pilot
called final girls
about a woman
who sort of rounded up a little bit like
x-men a little bit like avengers where
she rounded up the final girls from all
over the country
and they created a sort of force
so there were no more final girls it was
terrific written by a guy named jeff
dixon and
so i wasn't really aware of the final
girl phenomenon
until then which was not that long ago
i understand it now because there have
been so many movies made
after the fact
where there's
the la you know what is what is the
phrase the last man standing
you know the last final girl standing um
i do understand it i'm not sure i really
conceptually have a feeling about it
except i mean i'm so old and i'm still
doing it so that i feel like lori strode
has been a final girl apparently for a
very long time for 42 years remember
yeah
[Music]
just seeing so i i would say that
i don't attach to the final girl
idea i understand it exists
from a
intellectual idea
um i'm not sure i ever really
i don't think i own a t-shirt that says
you know final girl that can change
i'm embarrassed to say i'd never even
heard the term final girl until we were
making the 2018 halloween and our
amazing producer ryan turek who's also
the biggest horror fan in the world like
just hung his head down when i was like
what's a final girl
and he was did you do it
he was so sad he was so
pained that i didn't know that and he
was like we need to start your education
judy
um so that's when i i learned what a
final girl was when i was the final girl
but i think you have to have perspective
of it
if you have been a fan of these movies
if you're aware that there's is a
similar link in the chain and that the
link is that there's always a final girl
i think from an outside perspective i
can really understand why someone would
be interested in that phenomenon being
the
s
in this case the original one in this
little og action i'm not sure i have the
perspective to offer
much you know interesting commentary
[Music]
i think it's fun to see the people that
we look up to and admire and are excited
about
to see like
where are they at like where where are
they now
i mean is essentially what we do with
this woman
who kicks all this ass and
and
can live to tell the tale and then we
catch up with her 40 years later and we
see that
she has like
sequestered herself she has trained
herself she has groomed herself into
a killer and a hunter in the way that
her
you know ultimate nemesis michael myers
has also done i think that like
we see someone who's actually turned
herself into her tormentor
but like most women we don't believe her
and
i think it's interesting
what you know it's not like laurie
strode you know went to school and
studied psychology and got a lot of
therapy and went to al-anon and a.a and
did all the steps of all the programs
and is now teaching classes and people
are like oh let me ask you a question
like no she's like i'm gonna get him i'm
gonna get him i'm gonna get him or
because she was the only one nobody who
believed that he would come and that he
was still after her and he was still yes
that he was still gonna come back and i
think for so many of us that experienced
that trauma early in our life like
you k it's you can't i don't know how
you get over something like that well i
mean what just popped in my mind was you
know all these women that came forward
with harvey weinstein
nobody believed them
nobody would take them seriously until
they put their name on the line those
three first women who put their name on
the line with ronan farrow no everybody
else would say i can't i can't risk
my career by putting my name on this and
there's something about
not being understood
and people thinking you're crazy
that is in itself
violence
but because as soon as you
in the movie you realize what's going on
and that it's real
can you imagine how you would feel to me
that's the same thing that happens with
a final girl who just isn't understood
someone's coming
hold her i got her i got her go go baby
go
lori and karen are exactly where we left
them in the back of a truck with lori
bleeding out from a stomach wound
and
so lori is rendered impotent
in the ability to fight for herself but
what's beautiful is to watch the
transformation
of karen who spent 2018 saying you're
crazy don't come around me don't come
around me family you're dangerous
and being immediately then
the entire second movie
is really karen's evolution both the
grief
of the guilt
of not believing her of challenging her
mother all those years and now here her
mother is near death
and there's beautiful work
by this one
of having to
understand that
and and realize she may lose her mother
and protect you and then
once her mother survives
she then goes into full
protection mode for her mother and her
daughter and it's a beautiful role
reversal i would say in the movie it's
it's it's
it's a it's a beautiful portrayal i will
tell you
we killed michael
my grandmother set the fire
no one told you
told me what
michael myers is alive
[ __ ] yeah
yeah are you kidding because as i just
said
lori is now
lori is a wounded bird lori can't fight
for herself no off the top she can't and
so karen somebody's got to and karen
with all of the shame of her bad her bad
past behavior with all of the rage
that this is the reality that this man
took her husband that this man almost
killed her mother that this man
um has has put her daughter in abject
terror
this mama bear
moves forward in a very powerful way
[Music]
you